mais d'abord on revient sur l'épidémie
de bronchiolite qui sévit toujours dans
l'Hexagone les autorités parlent d'un
niveau d'hospitalisation sans précédent
depuis 10 ans à l'hôpital Clocheville de
tours on se prépare une cellule de crise
a été activée avec l'ouverture vendredi
dernier de 16 lits supplémentaires pour
les pathologies hivernales infectieuses
reportage avec Florent Clavel
dans la salle d'attente des urgences de
Clocheville ce matin un silence presque
fataliste certains parents patients ici
avec leur enfant depuis plusieurs heures
l'hôpital vient d'ailleurs de battre un
nouveau record d'affluence quand on
regarde notre tableau on constate que on
a une salle d'attente avec une trentaine
de patients on sait que d'emblée on
parle là sur entre 8 et 10 heures
d'attente pour les derniers arrivés
s'ils sont pas s'ils ont pas
d'estimations de niveau de gravité vous
avez déjà vu ça non voilà c'est à cette
heure là de la journée c'est j'ai jamais
vu ça
la coupable la bronchiolite l'affection
respiratoire à la fois plus précoce et
sévère cette année elle représente 10%
des consultations aux urgences
pédiatriques et près de la moitié des
bouches sur une hospitalisation pour y
faire face l'hôpital a décidé d'ouvrir
tous les lits de son unité saisonnière
avec deux semaines d'avance on a décidé
avec la direction d'ouvrir à 16 litres
dès vendredi soir et donc aujourd'hui on
a 14 patients sur les 16 vies donc c'est
vraiment une ouverture qui était
nécessaire par rapport à l'évolution de
l'épidémie de boncellite sur le
département
bonjour madame
si la bronchiolite se soigne bien au
bout de 5 à 10 jours c'est symptômes
restent impressionnants surtout sur des
nouveaux-nés il a du mal à respirer il a
du mal à s'alimenter et ça se dégrade
très vite donc faut vraiment être
vigilant et surveiller
attentivement en fait l'enfant et voir
si ça se dégrade aller tout de suite aux
urgences selon l'hôpital la situation
est pour l'instant sous contrôle même si
pour affronter cette vague de
bronchiolite il a fallu décaler
certaines opérations pédiatriques pour
les soignants le meilleur remède reste
encore aujourd'hui la prévention